what's up South Indian how you doing man
you bro what do you think I'm looking at
I'm looking at this Latino over
here no South Indian right I told you I
act like I'm not nice at this you're not
Malu though no oh look at this Christian
ass boy right here how you meet these
guys mission trip
South Indian hanging out with not South
Indians
trying to convert you twice these
y'all don't y'all didn't laugh at that
cause you didn't get it his great
grandparents were probably Hindu and
then some white people came to South
Indian were like look you got two
choices
you can either choose to believe in our
God or you could find out if your God
exists right now
[Laughter]
and she goes
you can't argue with Effectiveness you
know what I mean there's a good method